madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce dimanche 16 mai en
israël à la veille du scrutin le ciel se
dégage pour le candidat travailliste
ehud barak seul maintenant depuis le
retrait des autres candidats face à
benyamin netanyahu donné largement
perdant dans les sondages depuis 48
heures les scènes de violences se
multiplient à vauvert dans le gard mais
avec mort d'homme cette fois jeune de 18
ans tué par le propriétaire de la
voiture qu'ils s'apprêtaient à saccager
l'inquiétude en moselle autour de lusine
dambach où est assemblée la smart le
coprésident de daimlerchrysler donne six
mois à la petite voiture pour faire ses
preuves
sinon dit-il il arrête la production et
puis bien sûr nous irons à cannes pour
la sortie du film de raoul ruiz le temps
retrouvé une adaptation de proust
nous y retrouverons deux des interprètes
de ce film emmanuelle béart et vincent
perez de nouveaux renforts de
gendarmerie vont donc être dépêchée à
vauvert dans le gard après que des
scènes de violence se soit répétée la
nuit dernière
cette fois un jeune homme a été tué par
un des habitants du village vendredi
soir sept personnes avaient déjà été
blessées par balles au cours d'une
bagarre
karine comazzi et arnaud ardoin tous les
mourir j'ai déjà dû te démolir
personne n'a rien demandé il ya des
blessés j'ai découvert son sein d'un
état d'un tableau ou mal à un face à
face violent
les jeunes de la petite ville de vauvert
et les gendarmes s'affrontent depuis
deux jours ce matin ils ont tenu tête
aux forces de leur date une montée de
violence soudaine provoqué par la mort
d'un jeune de 18 ans tués cette nuit
alors qu'ils dégradent et un véhicule en
stationnement
mais tout démarre en fait dans la nuit
de vendredi à samedi un groupe de jeunes
saccage des commerces la tension monte
des bagarres et des coups de feu bilan
de la nuit sept blessés chez les jeunes
en réalité les habitants n'ont pas
accepté la libération d'un jeune ayant
frappé un policier municipal
ils accusent la justice d'être la cause
de ces émeutes
une situation qui de toute évidence
embarrasse les autorités judiciaires je
n'ai pas de commentaire une flambée de
violence qui divise vauvert d'un côté
des habitants indignés de l'autre des
jeunes qui réclame justice pour la mort
de leur ami l événement essentiel c'est
la mort d'un ami
on n'est pas des agresseurs nous ne
sommes pas armés le quart adverse entre
guillemets si je puis m'exprimer comme
ça parce que j'estime pas qui est des
pieds de côté le camp adverse
ils ont des armes le maire de son côté
tente de renouer le dialogue avec les
habitants de sa commune
tout ce que nous voulons faire
aujourd'hui c'était une coupure assez
longue renage parce que effectivement on
peut toujours accrocher quelque chose
d'autre chose donc on joue absolument
arrêter sans arrêter ça d'abord retrouvé
que la communauté retrouve tout son
calme
c'est ce à quoi nous employons ce matin
le meurtrier présumé du jeune homme a
été arrêté et placé en garde à vue cet
après midi
quadrillés par 120 gendarmes la petite
ville de vauvert semblait avoir retrouvé
son calme
une centaine de gendarmes de policiers
de douaniers aidés d'un hélicoptère
recherche d'un homme dans le département
de la moselle
il a d'abord tué quatre personnes en
allemagne non de à la sortie d'une
discothèque avant d'en abattre une
cinquième à sierck les bains
pour l'instant on ignore tout des
raisons qu'ils l'ont entraîné dans cette
cavale meurtrière on sait simplement
qu'il s'agit d'un ressortissant allemand
connu des services de police car
lindgren
tout l'après midi les gendarmes armés de
fusils à pompe revêtu de gilet pare
balles se sont postés autour de la
caserne désaffectée de sierck-les-bains
l'homme qu'il recherche pourraient
s'être retranchés à l'intérieur
âgé d'une quarantaine d'années il est
soupçonné d'avoir tué depuis ce matin 5
personnes en france et en allemagne
sa dernière victime a été retrouvé à 300
mètres de là un père de deux enfants à
quatre reprises dans sa fuite le
meurtrier a tenté de s'emparer de
plusieurs véhicules
le meurtrier a pris la fête au cours de
cette fête est là commis à plusieurs
reprises des violences graves contre les
personnes une jeune femme a été blessée
à la jambe et un pompier a également été
victime à l'oreille de débris de verre
c'est en allemagne à dillingen qu'a
débuté la folie meurtrière à 4h30 ce
matin il y avait encore une vingtaine de
clients dans la discothèque et xanadu
un inconnu a soudain ouvert le feu le
gérant est l'un des employés ont été
tués et trois autres personnes blessées
selon les témoins l'homme s'est frayé un
chemin vers la sortie en tirant puis il
s'est rendu dans un appartement dans sa
folle équipée
il a tué un couple franco-britannique et
blessé leur fille est pour l'instant les
motivations de cette tuerie ne sont pas
connues de l'homme
on ne connaît qu'un portrait robot il
serait tellement blond corpulent et
mesurerait 1 m 85
et puis dans le finistère c'est un
forcené qui a été tué par un gendarme
après qu'il ait lui-même blessé l'un de
ses collègues
l'actualité à l'étranger c'est d'abord
israël avec la à la veille du scrutin
qui doivent renouveler les membres de la
knesset et surtout désigner le nouveau
premier ministre
en l'espace de quelques heures tous les
petits candidats se sont retirés ne
laissant plus en lice qu'ehud barak pour
le parti travailliste et et benjamin
netanyahu pour le likoud
les chances du premier ministre sortant
de l'emporter par reste alors bien mince
charles enderlin
à moins de 24 heures du scrutin la
campagne électorale a basculé avec leur
retraite de trois candidats
en fin de matinée de 5 morts de rails le
chef du parti du sang ces sondages
favorables il ya seulement quelques
semaines se sont effrités au fil des
jours il appelle ses électeurs à voter
pour barack
durant l'après midi c'est l'extrême
droite qui renoncent benny begin retire
sa candidature mais ne se désiste pas en
faveur de netanyahu hier choix cette
tête
azmi bishara le premier arabe à briguer
la présidence du conseil de l'histoire
d'israël benyamin netanyahu ehud barak
reste seul en lice l'élection du premier
ministre se fera en lin tour à sal
demain tous les sondages prédisent une
large victoire du candidat de la gauche
qui pourrait obtenir jusqu'à 55% des
voix mais netanyahou ne s'avoue pas
vaincu loin de là ils multiplient les
mises en garde les travaillistes de
barack accepteront dit-il un état
palestinien qui menacerait l'existence
même d'israël
inlassablement il rappelle que les
instituts de sondage s'étaient trompés
lors de son élection en 1996 annonçait
la victoire de shimon peres et
d'attaquer la presse selon lui
entièrement acquise à la gauche
il a lancé au cours d'un meeting les
journalistes ont peur effet répété par
les militants ils ont peur ils ont peur
ehud barak lui ne veut pas vendre la
peau de l'ours
il poursuivra sa campagne jusqu'à la
fermeture des bureaux de vote demain à
21h quatre vingt mille militants de
gauche sont mobilisés pour surveiller le
bon déroulement du scrutin
cela alors que dans la rue les esprits
s'échauffent tôt ce matin une équipe de
la télévision israélienne a été attaqué
par des inconnus au nord de tel-aviv
hier des partisans de gauche et de
droite en sont venus aux m'appeler
d'ashkelon et ces images tournées par
france 2 en fait scandale ces jeunes qui
portent des t-shirts netanyahu scored on
a eu rabin
on leur a barré alors charles enderlin
bonsoir vous êtes à jérusalem vous
lisiez dans notre reportage tous les
sondages donnent et de mouthe barak
vainqueur certains prédisent même qu'il
pourrait l'emporter dès le premier tour
est ce que ça veut dire que les jeux
sont faits les jeux ne sont pas faits il
faut prendre ces sondages avec beaucoup
de précaution en 1996 un seul institut
avait prévu la victoire de benyamin
nétanyahou face à shimon peres
alors c'est vrai cette fois tous les
instituts annonce une victoire très
important des moubarak parfois avec une
avance de dix points sur benyamin
nétanyahou ce soir seuls quelques
astrologues et monsieur netanyahu lui
même prévoit une victoire que moi sa
victoire
mais l'électeur israéliens et parfois
imprévisibles y at il à l'heure qu'il
est peut-être jusqu'à demain soir
jusqu'à la fermeture des bureaux de vote
un retour des déçus de monsieur
netanyahou vers les la droite vers sa
candidature
des gens qui avaient quitté le likoud
pour le parti du centre et pour
l'extrême droite
c'est fort possible et puis de nombreux
militants considèrent les les instituts
de sondage comme faisant alliance avec
la presse de gauche
il déteste donne-t-il des réponses vrai
lorsqu ils ont les questions des
instituts
ce n'est pas toujours certain oui
charlie puis en ce qui concerne les
résultats maintenant ce sera j'imagine
demain soir très tard 22 heures
fermeture des bureaux de vote dont
israël 22h heure française nous aurons
les premières fourchette les premières
estimations des instituts de sondage sur
des sondages que même fond mais les
résultats véritables on les aura dans la
nuit si le résultat est très serré il
faudra attendre le décompte définitif et
la publication officielle des résultats
mercredi
merci charlie on suivra bien sûr tout
cela dans l'émission polémique et dans
les journaux de france 2 la guerre en
yougoslavie l'otan a dans ce soir
qu'elle va encore intensifié ses frappes
malgré les risques de tuer des civils
comme ce fut le cas à korytza sans être
catégorique l'alliance évoque de plus en
plus l'utilisation par les serbes des
réfugiés comme boucliers humains
ces dernières 24 heures les
bombardements se sont surtout
concentrées sur le sud du kosovo
stefano mme chan par cette colonne de
fumée visible à des kilomètres à la
ronde
il ne reste pas grand-chose du dépôt de
carburant de provo en serbie les raids
de l'otan se sont concentrés sur des
infrastructures la nuit dernière à bord
au sud est de belgrade les alliés ont
bombardé la plus grande mine de cuivre
de la ville faisant six blessés dont un
grave
le général américain wesley clark
commandant en chef des forces de l'otan
veut encore intensifier les frappes
il se dit prêt à utiliser dans les jours
à venir les hélicoptères apache tueur de
charme
le pentagone hésitent à donner son feu
vert belgrade affirme que c'est cette
montée en puissance qui freine son
retrait du kosovo l'otan nous demandent
de retirer nos troupes comme condition
préalable à l'arrêt des bombardements
mais elle fait tout pour que nous
n'arrivions pas à organiser ce retrait
sur le terrain après le bombardement
meurtrier de korytza slobodan milosevic
dénonce un exemple éclatant du caractère
génocidaire de l'agression de l'otan
dernier bilan serbe 87 morts civils et
78 blessés mais les alliés répète
inlassablement que la cible était
militairement légitime et il accuse
belgrade d'avoir utilisé des boucliers
humains
c'est la thèse de londres de bonnes et
de l'otan quand on connaît la
personnalité de milosevic on peut penser
que les réfugiés ont été utilisés non
seulement militairement mais aussi
politiquement l'a souvent fait par le
passé un mauvais film amateur vaut mieux
qu'une bonne photo satellite pour
frapper l'opinion publique
ce document diffusé opportunément
trouverez la réalité d'un massacre
orchestré par les serbes le 27 mars
dernier pour le pentagone
ces images confirment des photos de
tombes aligner déjà montré et légitime
l'action de l'otan pendant ce temps les
diplomates continue de travailler
une mission exploratoire de l'onu la
première du genre depuis le début du
conflit est arrivé aujourd'hui à
belgrade pour étudier les besoins
humanitaires du pays
est ce nécessaire à sa reconstruction et
en italie plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de personnes ont entamé une marche pour
la paix elle doit les conduire de la
ville de pérouse à celle d'assises il
s'agit bien sûr d'une marche pour
protester contre ces frappes de l'otan
à londres le secrétaire d'état
britannique estimons que de plus en plus
probable que les serbes est placée
délibérément des civils dans le village
de korytza comme boucliers humains
l'attak a fait je vous rappelle 87 morts
et 78 blessés
c'est également ce que disent les
responsables de loups checa qui
prédisent d'autres accidents de ce type
gérard griesbeck emmanuel bec que sont à
belgrade ils ont enquêté sur la
situation au kosovo pristina la capitale
du kosovo bombardé jour et nuit par
l'aviation de l'otan
les pilotes lâchent leurs bombes à
distance pour éviter les tirs de l'adc
acerbes résultats des maisons sont
souvent détruites par erreur paradoxe de
cette guerre propre pour préserver la
sécurité des militaires
on sacrifie des civils
de retour du kosovo paul marie de la
gorce témoigne
bezina vire à l'heure de ses activités
habituelles pendant une partie de la
journée mais en partie de la population
n'est plus là des tensions subsistent
entre les albanais qui vivent encore
christina il y en a j'en ai rencontré
j'en ai vu et ils m'ont parlé
et puis naturellement la communauté
serbe et les autorités civiles et
militaires serbes mais vous avez à
partir de 4-5 heures du soir et d'art
davantage encore
c'est une ville le vide et silencieuse
il reste environ 35000 serbe et 65000
albanais soit un tiers de serbes pour
deux tiers des albanais depuis le début
des bombardements toutes les écoles de
serbie ont été fermés selon le temps ces
écoles servirait d'abri pour l'armée
d'où les nombreuses frappes sur les
bâtiments scolaires la guerre sous
toutes ses formes à accélérer l'exode
des albanais bien entendu certains sont
partis à la suite aux représailles
exercées par la communauté serbe et les
éléments armés de la communauté serbe
voulais te régler leur compte aux
combattants de lui ces cas qui ont été
leurs ennemis des périodes antérieures
il ya eu des affrontements très dur il y
a ceux qui ont tout simplement voulu
échapper aux bombardements
c'est indiscutable comme partout dans le
monde et j'en ai vu à de nombreuses
reprises dans ma vie et dans ma vie
professionnelle ont fui les régions qui
sont cons barbe et beaucoup de gens ont
naturellement fui les zones bombardées
il ya ceux qui ont voulu quitter les
zones de combat et dans les premiers
jours de la guerre l'armée yougoslave a
tenté de liquider les maquis de lui ses
cadres il ya des affrontements très dur
dont on voit des traces partout mais ont
brûlé en partie démolis et ça fait un
contingent supplémentaire de départ et
puis il ya naturellement ceux qui ont
été expulsés de leurs maisons par
l'armée qui avait besoin de cantonnement
où qui peut-être ne désirez pas avoir
immédiatement à proximité des lunes
population la réputée aussi vu il ya la
contagion donc tous les exodes joue un
rôle et fait que quand les voisins
partent quand les parents par dont on
parle aussi
du côté des réfugiés maintenant 800
personnes ont pu franchir le poste
frontière à blatche et entre le kosovo
et la macédoine c'est l'arrivée la plus
importante depuis que le poste avait été
fermé le 5 mai dernier le secrétaire
général de l'alliance javier solana a
précisé que le but de l'otan était de
leur permettre de rentrer chez eux avant
l'hiver remontés les grosses et l'armée
yougoslave qui empêche les réfugiés de
quitter cette république pour se rendre
en albanie au passage elle en profite
pour arrêter les hommes de plus de 18
ans reportage anne consigny et didier
dans la police monténégrine a placé
aujourd'hui une voiture d'escort devant
les convois de plus de réfugiés pour
éviter que ne se reproduise ce qui est
arrivé hier
ces femmes venaient de quitter avec
leurs familles quand du monténégro en
direction de l'albanie mais à deux
kilomètres de la frontière l'armée
fédérale yougoslave a ordonné aux hommes
de 16 à 60 ans de descendre elles ont
donc passé la nuit ici à proximité du
lieu d'arrestation
ils ont descendu les hommes et les ont
fait entrer dans la caserne juste à côté
il nous en dit qu'on pouvait aller en
albanie au faire demi tour
quand on a demandé des nouvelles à la
cellule de crise pour les réfugiés ils
nous ont dit qu'on les avait renvoyés au
kosovo faute de nouvelles officielles
les familles des hommes interpellés sont
repartis cet après-midi dans leur camp
au monténégro au moins on tels que
prévenir hier les bus arrivant derrière
elle qu'il ne fallait plus s'approcher
de la frontière
reste à attendre car il n'est plus
question pour elle de quitter le
monténégro on veut bien partir en
albanie mais à condition qu'ils nous
rendent les hommes
ça dépend de leur volonté cette affaire
est un nouvel épisode de la lutte plus
ou moins ouverte que se livrent les
autorités monténégrines soutenus par
leur police et belgrade
fortement représentée ici par l'armée
fédérale yougoslave
ces arrestations constituent une
provocation pour le monténégro qui tente
de rester neutre dans le conflit et qui
considèrent les réfugiés comme ses hôtes
et toujours remonter les gros mais sur
l'autre frontière avec la bosnie l'armée
s'est déployée là aussi pour empêcher et
les conscrits où les réservistes de fuir
le pays
demain l'émission mots croisés sera
consacrée aux questions que l'on peut se
poser sur le conflit du kosovo
arlette chabot alain duhamel recevront
des hommes politiques comme alain
madelin jack lang daniel cohn-bendit ou
encore marie france garaud et puis il y
aura aussi des témoignages du kosovo est
une interview exclusive du frère du
président milosevic
la décrue du rhin à se confirme après
quatre jours de montée des eaux le
niveau du fleuve a commencé à baisser
que ce soit en allemagne en france ou en
suisse même si la situation est toujours
qualifiée de critique par les autorités
de berne d'où viennent ces images en
allemagne deux garçons 2 1 et 6 ans sont
toujours portées disparues probablement
victime de cette crue mercredi soir un
garçon de 5 ans était déjà noyé près de
fribourg
les vingt-cinq sapeurs-pompiers de paris
partis en renfort pour aider leurs
collègues d'abidjan continuent à se
battre contre le feu ils essayent de
maîtriser le gigantesque incendie qui
consume depuis jeudi 23 millions de
litres d'essence et d'aidés militaires
français basés à abidjan
il était presque parvenu à étouffer
l'incendié
de la mousse mais le feu semble-t-il a
repris c'est l'inquiétude en moselle
autour de l' usine d'assemblage de la
smart locaux prédisent encore au
président de daimler chrysler a donné un
ultimatum aux dirigeants de lusine si
dans six mois au plus les résultats ne
sont pas plus satisfaisant
la production sera arrêtée à hambach
l'usiné emploie 1700 salariés jérôme
soûlard et sylvain gauthier une
impressionnante tour de verre celle de
smart symbole d'une prospérité retrouvée
pour la lorraine un rayon de soleil dans
le ciel de sarreguemines très vite
obscurci par une commercialisation pour
l'instant très décevante alors que la
presse locale continue ce matin ne
publier des annonces d'embauchés pour
smart
le patron du géant dames l'air chrysler
vient lui de donner un délai de six mois
pour redresser la barre faute de quoi le
projet serait stoppée ce genre de
discours tenu par le secret avec les
médiateurs du groupe d'amis à qui cela
est plutôt étonnant l'usiné temps étant
si moderne sa canne de dommage de gâcher
un tel investissement avec des gens qui
sont pratiquement tous bilingues et
touche très compétent 200000 ventes par
an c'était les prévisions soixante mille
c'est le piètre résultat de cette année
qui n'a pourtant jamais effrayé les
salariés de l'usiné
je compte beaucoup sur cette usine je
pense pas que plus fort mais comme ça
alors
quand même mercedes car quand les
responsables et tout ça en vaut je pense
pas qu'elle va fermer la disparition de
smart les élus lorrains très engagé dans
ce projet depuis cinq ans ne peuvent
même pas l'imaginer
trop de choses sont engagés dans cette
affaire là pour qu'on puisse en rester
là
les pouvoirs publics l'argent de l'état
l'argent du département l'argent de la
région
inauguration par le président de la
république visites de ministres et sa
ferme vrai comme ça à mon sens mans pour
moi l'espoir subsiste dans les heures
qui viennent les représentants syndicaux
de l'entreprise devrait demander la
tenue d'un ce extraordinaire
un rendez-vous à stuttgart avec le
patron du géant mercedes a même été
évoquée
1700 personnes ont aujourd'hui trouvé du
travail dans ce qu'on appelle ici
smartville la ville usine
c'est donc toute une région qui attend
désormais dans l'inquiétude des
nouvelles de son avenir
puis je vous rappelle que vous avez
jusqu'à demain soir dernier délai pour
vous acquitter du deuxième tiers
provisionnel
après ce sera 10 % de plus la politique
avec d'abord la phrase d'elisabeth
guigou chez nos confrères de radio j au
lendemain de la grande manifestation
nationaliste ajaccio en corse
et alors que nicolas sarkozy et philippe
douste-blazy annonce qu'il se prépare à
déposer une motion de censure sur cette
question le garde des sceaux réaffirme
la politique du gouvernement avant de
s'en prendre à la droite insulaire
je crois que la droite en corse
manifeste je dirais complaisance et même
quelquefois une connivence que je trouve
coupable à l'égard
à l'égard des thèses nationalistes le
gouvernement n'a pas l'intention de
changer de politique et cette politique
c'est celle du respect de la loi il faut
que la loi soit respectée en corse comme
partout ailleurs sur le territoire de la
république
alors les nationalistes manifestent
c'est leur droit
on est dans un pays de libre expression
mais ce que le gouvernement ne tolère
pas et ne tolérera pas davantage c'est
la violence c'est les actes terroristes
et devant nos confrères de rmc le ton
était totalement différent avec arlette
laguiller alain krivine
ils ont défendu le droit à
l'autodétermination du peuple corse
le couple laguiller et krivine est en
lice pour les élections européennes vous
le savez d'après les derniers sondages
ils sont crédités d'un peu plus de 6%
des intentions de vote
laurent hakim et yanji qu'elles ont
suivi arlette laguiller en campagne
c'est une voisine comment elle est comme
voisine très courtois polis gentils
abordable pour ses voisins c'est arlette
tout court dans sa cité hlm de seine
saint denis arlette simple militante
devenue conseillère municipale puis
régional et bientôt peut-être député
européen parlement qui a pas beaucoup de
pouvoir
en quarante ans de militantisme la
pasionaria de lutte ouvrière n'a jamais
cédé à la lassitude eux mêmes face au
combat perdu d'avancé
alors pour ces européennes elle bat la
campagne avec la même énergie encore
sous l'effet de son score aux
présidentielles de 95 et de son élection
au conseil régional d'île de france
ce jour-là destination perpignan avec
alain krivine son nouveau complice de la
ligue communiste révolutionnaire il
somnole en classe économique
elle disserte en classe affaires mais
sur le fond c'est classe ouvrière pour
tous le dossier corse et à la une
le moment
sur ce coup là
des normes sociales on n'a pas tenu ses
promesses et pendant qu'arles est good
subrepticement au plaisir des embruns
les jeunes révolutionnaires veulent
croire à l'union sacrée
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça vaut le coup de
se réunir pour marquer pour faire
comprendre aux gens redonner espoir
reconstruire l'espoir des deux
organisations différentes ce qui nous
empêche pas de faire une campagne quand
même origine en vedette américaine pour
chauffer la salle
empruntés aux rugbymen du xiii catalan
et puis l'imperturbable idéalisme
d'arlette laguillier ici notre liste
dépassait les 10%
ce serait l'expression d'une
radicalisation de l'opinion des salariés
des chômeurs des jeunes et d'une reprise
de la confiance de la population
laborieuse en ses capacités d'imposer
une autre politique
l'international comme générique de fin
le prochain meeting sera un nouveau
combat on ne parle que de cela sur le
vieux port à marseille les pêcheurs
veulent que l'on déclare l'état de
catastrophe naturelle après l invasion
des méduses
elles sont particulièrement nombreuses
cette année ce qui ne gêne pas encore
vraiment les baigneurs mais alourdit et
brise parfois les filets des pêcheurs
yannick à rossi et jean-françois
giorgetti fait une heure et demie
à bord du chalutier les visages sont
tendus inquiet la sortie est un test
malheureusement conclure les méduses qui
au gré du mistral avait disparu de la
surface sont toujours bien là dans les
fonds de la rade de marseille
la pêche a duré dix minutes autant de
méduses queue de poisson
continuez serait de la folie avec un
coup sûr de gros dégâts pour le filet et
des pertes d'exploitation supplémentaire
n'a pas les reins solides
avoir beaucoup de l'argent pour
quand les quais prennent des allures
d'ateliers décidé éventré déchirer les
centaines de kilos de méduses bush les
mailles de ces chalut à 60 mille francs
qui explose sous la pression les dégâts
qui m'a amené le bateau et a cassé cette
file et janet pourra au moins trois mois
à tout remettre en état
résultat les bateaux restent au port les
pêcheurs demandent que la situation soit
considérée comme catastrophes naturelles
le phénomène est bel est bien naturel
surprenant si tôt dans la saison mais
logique
il a plu relativement beaucoup tant que
les rivières ont amené des sels
nutritifs le plancton se développer et
de ce fait les méduses ont trouvé
davantage de nourriture la méduse est un
animal méconnu qui va au gré des vents
et des courants
rien ne permet de dire si la saison
touristique sera ou non gâché quand même
des baigneurs la f1 et le doublé
historique de ferrari au grand prix de
monaco où michael schumacher l'a emporté
devant son coéquipier l'irlande irvine
david coulthard tu lui sur mclaren a dû
abandonner patrick naf des pointes à
près de 300 km heure entre les rails
monaco c'est d'abord un numéro de haute
voltige ça doit passer au millimètre
mais parfois ça ne passe pas il
diniz herbert et barrichello en font
l'expérience
neuf voitures seulement ont franchi la
ligne d'arrivée du quatrième grand prix
de la saison
un grand prix dominée de bout en bout
par michael schumacher qui passe à
killem dès le premier freinage suiveurs
vine coulthard barrichello et trulli à
lisier 15e panis 18e schumacher est à
l'attaqué et il dépasse les premiers
attardés après 10 tours de course à
peine en fait il y à lui et les autres
la mclaren de coulthard fume derrière
find me dessine il abandonne peu après
quand le moteur de takagi explosé que à
clymène alors 2e tire tout droit à cause
de son huile c'est une aubaine de plus
pour schumacher qui en profitent pour
ravitailler hakkinen lui cède sa
deuxième place sur vannes en s'arrêtant
du coup c'est un doublé ferrari
le premier de la scuderia à monaco
autant dire que jean clottes et ses
pilotes ont vraiment de quoi être
heureux ce soir
un mot de tennis pour vous signaler la
cuisante défaite de julie halard autour
note berlin balayée par la suissesse
martina hingis en 40 minutes et deux
sets 6-0 et 6-1
le cyclisme deuxième étape du tour
d'italie et victoire au sprint de mario
ciccolini qui endosse le maillot rose de
leader
mais ce giro version 99 est marqué par
les affaires de dopage
christelle bertrand et mathieu dreujou
ce n'est jamais facile de se remettre en
selle quand un coureur de l'équipe s'est
fait expulser shekels mes balades
l'ambiance n'est pas à la rigolade les
affaires de dopage c'est du sérieux
sauf pour la télévision italienne qui a
choisi la dérision l'émission s'appelle
le procès de l'étape en direct et tous
les jours les journalistes ont choisi de
mener leur propre enquête
les questions sont simples et sans dès
qu'il jure que tu ne feras jamais de
tours de magie pour gagner je ne suis
pas magicien donc je n'emploie pas de
trucs mais tu le jure oui je jure mais
personne ne peut jurer participer au
tour de france
surtout pas laurent jalabert pour le
français à chaque jour suffit sa peine
savannah par la commission
je dis simplement qu'après du tour
d'italie son tour la premier tour de
suisse juste avant le tour je verrai si
charmante commission d'en faire le tour
ou pas marco pantani vainqueur du tour
d'italie et du tour de france l'année
dernière
exit aussi les vedettes savent se faire
désirer je prendrai ma décision après le
giro si je suis bien ici peut-être que
je ferai le tour mais peut être
seulement le seul qui n'hésite pas c'est
le public
il est là nombreux il n'y a que pour les
autres grâce que c'est chacun son tour
nantes a fait la fête aujourd'hui pour
célébrer les vainqueurs de la coupe de
france une belle équipe nantaise
particulièrement prometteuse cette
antenne est jeune mais une victoire
contestée à sedan où l'on se souviendra
longtemps du penalty accordé très
généreusement par l' arbitre ce fut je
vous rappelle le seul but du match
la suite des quarts de finale du
championnat de france de rugby après
bourgoin et le stade toulousain hier ce
sont mon ferrand et grenoble qui se sont
qualifiés pour les demi finales en
battant respectivement castres et
colomiers nous allons maintenant à
cannes pour une montée des marches qui
en impose avec l'équipe du film de raoul
ruiz en compétition officielle le temps
retrouvé d'après l'oeuvre de marcel
proust la distribution vous le voyez
était insolente avec catherine deneuve
emmanuelle béart marie france pisier
john malkovich ou encore vincent perez
le temps retrouvé
c'est l'un des quatre films représentant
la france dans la compétition officielle
alors avant d'aller retrouver nos
invités autour de pascal deschamps
puisque nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir
emmanuelle béart et vincent perez
bonsoir à vous voyons d'abord avec
michel mon comté et jean-louis melun
comment raoul ruiz s'est attaqué à
l'oeuvre de proust une ambition
difficile quand on sait que des
réalisateurs comme l'oseo visconti avait
préféré renoncer
ne cherchez pas la plage de baalbeck sur
une carte elle n'existe pas
ou plutôt n'existe que parce qu'un
certain marcel proust l'a rêvé en
incarnant ce rêve
le réalisateur raoul ruiz réveil des
fantômes plus vivant que bien le divin
la grand-mère toujours inquiète
et ce petit marcel toujours si fragile
le tout sous l'oeil impérial et
concupiscent de l'éternel charlut baron
de guermantes
au coeur d'un kaléidoscope complexe jean
louis s'est donc attaché à reconstituer
ce qui fut l'époque de proust ces salons
ces mondanités
ces beautés
mais aussi ses coups le fleuret méchante
régions du monde méchant mais toujours
si spirituel un univers habité
passionnément partout les croustilles
elle où elle arrive ici sans prévenir
comme ça
je vieillis au japon
vous rêvez ma chère elle est superbe
chers amis quel plaisir de vous
paraissez je n'y croyais plus tout ce
qu'on a construit sa mère
et rarement on a forcément envie de
mettre un visage
rentrer compris quelque chose
l'excitation dans lequel avec s'approche
joyeuse et tourner autour du pot
mettre des visages sur les rêves
proustien maître des rêves proustien sur
le visage des acteurs
voilà quel a été le mérite du travail ô
combien proustien du réalisateur raoul
ruiz
comment menez-vous dans des matinées si
nombreuse pour trouver dans une grande
cure et comme cela ce n'est pas ainsi
que je vaux schématiser on vérifie je
m'attendais à vous trouver partout
ailleurs qu un des grand tralala nathan
incarnation de rêve
est-ce que c'est aussi ça la magie du
cinéma
alors emmanuelle béart et vincent perez
heureux bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce soir et avec pascal
deschamps emmanuelle béart comment avez
vous vécu cette cette entrée dans deux
univers difficile celui de proust bien
sûr et puis celui de raul ruiz vous
dites vous même que vous n'avez jamais
pu le lire proust je crois enfin j'ai
dit que j'ai essayé pendant des années
de lire proust et que j'ai j'ai
finalement réussi grâce à ruiz grâce à
relever ce pourquoi tueur et non dis moi
que tu as tout du proust toi mais je
suis rentrée dans cet univers avec ce
personnage de gilbert qui est un
personnage qui est le premier amour du
narrateur le premier amour celui qu'on
n'oublie pas celui le premier regard la
première jouissance si je crois du
narrateur puisqu'il elle a joué en
jouant avec le personnage de gilberte
voilà je suis rentré avec avec tous mais
tous mes camarades dont vincent dont
catherine deneuve donc qui jouent aux
dettes puisque gilbert tu es la fille de
soigner de dette
et puis tous les autres alors justement
vincent vous jouez morel qui est un
musicien on va dire ambitieux qui
traverse les lits de plusieurs
personnages puissent par arrivisme que
par amour
comment vous trouvez le regard de proust
et le regard de ruiz donc sur cette
société sur ces gens ces sociétés un peu
en décadence donc je le trouve plutôt
réaliste et pas vraiment cruel
je trouve que ruiz a réussi son pari
parce qu'il a trouvé la petite porte
secrète pour entrer dans l'univers de
proust qui est le détail le sens du
détail et le cinéma est fait de détail
et donc du coup tous et rejoint j'ai un
patient en voyant le film la force de
détails la magie est menée et donc du
coup cette magie ressemblent à autant à
ruiz cap proust et donc du coup il ya
une chanson j'ai l'impression qu'ils se
sont trouvés là et à partir de ce moment
là il ya une liberté qu'est né ce qu'on
ressent en voyant le film est qui et qui
est nécessaire pour que le film ne soit
pas on ne rentre pas dans une idée de
mode et contrairement aux autres filles
mots qui ont été faits sur proust je
trouve qu'ils ont été un peu trop fait
de clichés qu'on l'avait de proust
celui-là il échappe à sa tout en jouant
avec peut-être des clichés mais il
échappe complètement à ce qu'on avait
déjà fait sur proust pour la première
fois je crois que proust c'est vraiment
bien rendus au cinéma
alors il échappa ça justement parce que
raoul ruiz a pris des risques il a fait
des choix
est-ce que vous avez l'impression même
si chaque film est un risque qu en
acceptant de faire celui là ce qu'on dit
que c'est inadaptable un pari impossible
etc
vous avez pris des risques ou qu'on vous
a fait prendre des risques que vous
n'aviez pas prises auparavant
oui j'ai l'impression mais je vois ce
que j'ai ressenti au tournage c'était un
véritable parti pris et il me semblait
que le rôle de l'acteur qui dans nos 40
kahn sont que des boulons dans une
chaîne et qu'il est important de garder
cet esprit de groupe est de savoir si
sean may tard est votre vision des
perles et il était important de 1 peu de
devenir comme proust
on a parlé de procès comme un lieu un
lieu réceptif à toutes les sensations à
tous les sens l'odorat l'ouïe le goût et
c'était voilà le travail que j'ai essayé
de faire moi c'était de devenir
complètement aller coûte on est à
d'acuité permanente et et de vous
laisser guider parce que je savais comme
l'a dit et vincent que les détails tous
ces petits détails du présent qui
replonge à travers les couloirs du passé
vers des situations déjà vécues sont des
choses qui
sensation que moi je connais la pression
tout pardon oui oui emmanuel bury et au
vu du résultat choix vous avez vu le
film hier je pensais votre père c'est
réussi vous êtes vous êtes contenté de
vous et du film et de rui gt gt été très
frappé par le fait que tout est est en
décalage en permanence y compris mon
émotion celle de mon père puisque c'est
avec mon père que j'ai vu hier soir
drôle de hasard cette drôle d'impression
d'avoir envie de pleurer mais jamais au
moment où enfin pas forcément en
relation avec ce qu'on voit dans
l'immédiat c'est que tout est décalé y
compris d'émotion qu'on a écouté merci
beaucoup à vous pascal je crois que vous
avez assisté à la première projection il
ya la projection officielle là d'ici
quelques instants et pour l'instant
c'est relativement bien accueilli le
film
oui vous savez à cannes la journée
s'organise en fait autour de deux rendez
vous d'abord la projection de huit
heures et demie où les gens de la presse
du cinéma découvre le film et la
projection officielle dont il ya lieu en
ce moment et emmanuel et 20 soit
justement d'aller à la fin de cette
projection à 9h10 pour voir les
réactions du public
donc ce matin après la séance de 8h30 eh
bien il ya eu beaucoup de beaucoup d'
écoute pendant toute la projection
et puis des applaudissements et même si
je dois dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont
des réserves
cette projection est accueillie avec
beaucoup de respect et c'est normal
parce que raoul ruiz et son équipe ont
pris un sacré risque
d'abord parce que les gens les fans de
proust les fidèles de proust et
proustien risque d'être déconcerté et
les gens qui ne connaissent pas proust
et bas il faut les amener quand même
dans cet univers est très inquiet trek
est très complexe très subtil donc ne
serait ce que pour cette raison la glace
est un film qui qui mérite le respect en
tout cas parce qu'elle remercie beaucoup
donc emmanuelle béart et vincent perez
d'avoir accepté d'être avec nous ce soir
on les les supportes davance pour la
projection officielle et puis on les
félicite et on est d'avoir osé
s'attaquer avec raoul ruiz à se filmer
cette oeuvre la merci beaucoup en tout
cas je vous invite maintenant à partir
vomissent carrosse dans les landes où
tous les deux ans est organisé un
rassemblement d'hydravion l'endroit n'a
pas été choisi par hasard puisque
biscarrosse c'était dans les années 30
ou 40
l'un des hauts lieux de l'aéronautique
éric perrin les frais des grains chèque
maman les p'tits bateaux qui vont sur
l'eau ont-ils des ailes bien oui mon
gros nigo s'il n'en avait pas il ne
volerait pas bateau qui vole l'avion qui
flottent qu'importe l'hydravion et bien
cet appareil hybride qui permet d'avoir
les pieds dans l'eau la tête dans les
nuages
depuis sept ans 10 carrosse réunis
autour de son immense lac ces chevaliers
de l'eau et du ciel tous ces avions
appartiennent à des particuliers comme
david neeman un pilote à la logique
toute british bien j'aime volet j'aime
les bateaux c'est une combinaison
parfaite dès demain eh bien ça
m'apprendra à poser des questions
idiotes
enfin pour tous ceux qui veulent mieux
comprendre voici pour la modique somme
d'un 365e de redevance télé un baptême
de l'air et de l'eau
lorsque vous décollez vous avez d'abord
la sensation d'être sereins au shore à
des bateaux à grande vitesse
quand vous quittez l'eau c'est la
liberté de voler davantage avec un
hydravion c'est que vous n'êtes pas
prisonnier des pistes d'atterrissage d
amerrir comme vous le voulez il y a
beaucoup plus de liberté
des hydravions et non des moindres il
s'en est posé sur ce lac de biscarrosse
dans les années 30 et 40 faute de piste
terrestre assez longue les seuls avions
transatlantiques étaient des hydravions
la plupart étaient fabriqués dans les
usines latécoère installés ici mme
charles métadier 75 ans y était
électricien monteur il a notamment
participé à la fabrication du plus grand
hydravion du monde
le latécoère 631 du terminal d'air
france installé au bord du lac on
embarquait pour buenos aires au new york
à bord de ces paquebots volant du grand
luxe
et il fallait bien parfois les six
kilomètres du lac pour que le pilote
finissent par arracher de l'eau les 72
tonnes d'acier
nous étions très fiers on assistait au
décollage de jour comme de nuit et de
nuit c'était une féerie aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus que pour la lutte contre les
incendies que les hydravions reste
indispensable hommage du canadair à ses
glorieux ancêtres un largage pour le
plaisir
spectacle de circonstance déconfite ide
au virevoltant dans l'air c'est bientôt
la fin de ce journal je vous rappelle je
vous en rappelle les principaux titres
en israël à la veille du scrutin le ciel
se dégage pour le candidat travailliste
ehud barak
seul maintenant depuis le retrait des
autres candidats face à des niemi
netanyahu donné largement perdant dans
les sondages depuis 48 heures les scènes
de violences se multiplient à vauvert
dans le gard mais avec mort d'homme 7
points un jeune de 18 ans tué par le
propriétaire de la voiture qu'ils
s'apprêtaient à saccager
dans un instant la météo à 20h50 copycat
avec sigourney weaver et holly hunter
23h15 dans le cadre des magazines ligne
de vie filles de banlieue un magazine
qui donne la parole à ces jeunes filles
de toutes origines qui vise évidemment
dans les banlieues des grandes villes
amies lui dise le journal de france
duprat demain 7h 50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra frédérique
bredin à 20h vous retrouverez bien sûr
claude sérillon dans un nouveau décor
et puis n'oubliez pas plus tard mots
croisés spécial kosovo bonne soirée sur
france 2